COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
NOW COME TO ORDER. AND FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME WE HAVE A
DELEGATION FROM ARGENTINA AND
THE STATE OF SANTA FE HERE
VISITING US. THEY'RE GOING TO BE
IN TOWN FOR ALMOST A WEEK. NOT
ALL IN SACRAMENTO, BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE'RE
REALLY THRILLED TO HAVE YOU. SO
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO WATCH
THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. AND I'D
LIKE TO INVITE SENATOR, SENATOR
ALLEN TO SAY ANY WORDS HE'D LIKE
TO. WELL, JUST WE HAVE A SISTER
STATE RELATIONSHIP WITH SANTA
FE, THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WE'VE WE'VE HAD DELEGATIONS THAT
HAVE GONE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
THE TWO STATES FOR MANY YEARS.
DIEGO. MY GOOD, GOOD FRIEND, HAS
BEEN LEADING THESE THESE TRIPS
BACK AND FORTH FOR, FOR QUITE
SOME TIME. AND THEY'RE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA VISITING. THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BE GOING TO
SAN FRANCISCO, I THINK LATER
TODAY. BUT THEY THEY'VE BEEN
HERE FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS IN THE
CAPITAL, AND THEN THEY'RE GOING
TO BE GOING TO CHICAGO, I THINK
FOR THE, FOR THE CONVENTION
DEMOCRAT CONVENTION, WHICH WILL
BE FUN. BUT IT'S A IT'S A
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP. AND I
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO GET TO
KNOW THE FOUNDATION THAT IS
THAT'S THAT'S WORKING ON TRYING
TO BRING GREATER LEGISLATIVE
DIALOG. WE WERE PLANNING ON
MEETING AT 930, AND THEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN WE HAD TO HAVE THIS
BILL, WHICH I'M EXCITED ABOUT.
SO I THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE FUN FOR
THEM TO COME AND SEE THE
PROCEEDINGS. THEY'RE ALL
SENATORS FROM SANTA FE. AWESOME.
YES. MR. PORTANTINO, IF I COULD
ADD A FEW WORDS, I'M ANTHONY
PORTANTINO, SENATOR FROM
BURBANK, GLENDALE, PASADENA. BUT
I GREW UP IN NEW JERSEY AND I,
ONE OF MY SADDEST, ISSUES AS A,
AS A YOUNG PERSON IN THE 70S IS
A GROUP OF ARGENTINIAN ITALIANS
WOULD COME VISIT MY GRANDFATHER
AND THEY WERE CALLED THE
COUSINS, AND THEY WOULD JUST
COME AND SPEND MONTHS FROM
ARGENTINA. BUT I HAVE NO WAY OF
TRACKING DOWN WHO THESE PEOPLE,
BECAUSE ALL OF MY RELATIVES HAVE
PASSED. BUT THEY WOULD LITERALLY
THIS GROUP OF FOUR MEN, BROTHERS
WOULD COME VISIT MY GRANDFATHER
FROM ARGENTINA ALMOST EVERY
SUMMER AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
FIGURE OUT WHO THEY WERE, BUT
THOSE THAT'S MY CONNECTION TO
ARGENTINA. AND OF COURSE, I WILL
CLAIM MESSI AS BEING ITALIAN
JUST FOR THE RECORD. SO
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS HE'S BOTH
ARGENTINIAN AND ITALIAN. SO
ANYWAY, WELCOME AND GLAD YOU'RE
HANGING OUT WITH ONE OF MY
FAVORITE LEGISLATORS. SO BE
WELL. WE'RE WE'RE REALLY
THRILLED YOU'RE HERE. SO THANK
YOU FOR COMING TO WATCH THIS
COMMITTEE. SO WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM YET. A QUORUM IS FOUR
SENATORS. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE. SO WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE OUR AUTHOR HERE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN IS PRESENTING ON
AB 3184. SO WITH THAT YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR MEASURE. THANK YOU
CHAIR. AND I'D JUST LIKE TO
START WITH A QUESTION, WHICH IS
WHEN ARE WE GOING ON A FACT
FINDING MISSION FOR SENATOR, FOR
SENATOR PORTANTINO TO FIND THE
COUSINS TO ARGENTINA. AND WE
NEED TO DO THAT. DIEGO WILL
ORGANIZE, CARRY THE BAGS. YEAH.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE, IN OUR IN OUR LAST GENERAL
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER OF 2022,
NEARLY 50% OF REJECTED VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS IN CALIFORNIA WERE
FOR EITHER A MISSING OR A
NON-MATCHING SIGNATURE. AND
THAT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF BALLOTS. THAT WAS
NEARLY 60,000 BALLOTS. WERE
REJECTED FOR EITHER A MISSING OR
A NON-MATCHING SIGNATURE, AND AB
3184 WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR VOTERS TO CURE
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT SIGNATURE
ISSUES. THIS NOVEMBER, TO HAVE
THEIR VOICE HEARD AND THEIR VOTE
COUNTED. RIGHT NOW, IF THERE IS
A MISMATCHING OR MISSING
SIGNATURE ON THE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT ENVELOPE, OUR ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS NOTIFY THE VOTER OF
THE PROBLEM AND HOW TO CORRECT
IT, AND THAT THE VOTER HAS UNTIL
5 P.M. TWO DAYS PRIOR TO THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE ELECTION.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT VOTERS MAY
NOT KNOW WHEN A COUNTY IS GOING
TO CERTIFY THE ELECTION, AND SO
THEY MAY DO THE WORK TO CORRECT
THE DEFICIENCY, ONLY TO FIND OUT
THAT THEY WERE TOO LATE AND
THEIR VOTE DOESN'T COUNT. AB
3184 WOULD SPECIFY THAT COUNTIES
CANNOT CERTIFY THE ELECTION
RESULTS UNTIL THE 28TH DAY,
UNTIL THE 28TH DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION, AND THAT VOTERS IN
CAMPAIGNS HAVE UNTIL THE 26TH
DAY TO FIX SIGNATURE ISSUES.
THIS MAXIMIZES THE TIME TO
CORRECT A SIGNATURE ISSUE AND
ENSURE THAT THE VOTE IS COUNTED,
AND PROVIDES A DATE CERTAIN, SO
THAT EVERYONE, EVERY VOTER, IS
OPERATING ON A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD. THE BILL RETAINS ITS
PREVIOUS CONTENT ON BALLOT
REJECTION REPORTS AND ALSO
INCLUDES SEVERAL QUITE TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO ALSO IMPROVE THE
BALLOT CURE PROCESS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WELL,
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN, DO YOU HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? I THINK
I'M JUST ME TODAY. OKAY. DO WE
HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER SUPPORT? I
DO NOT SEE ANY. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY? I DO NOT
SEE ANY IN THE ROOM. SO I WOULD
JUST. I'LL JUST SUMMARIZE AND
YOU CAN CONFIRM IF THIS IS TRUE.
SO IN CALIFORNIA, WE SEND A
BALLOT TO EVERY VOTER AND THEY
CAN FOR AN ENTIRE MONTH. THEY
CAN DECIDE WHO THEY WANT TO VOTE
FOR, AND THEY FILL OUT THEIR
BALLOT AT HOME. AND THEN THEY
PUT A STAMP. THEY ACTUALLY DON'T
PUT A STAMP ON IT. THERE'S
ALREADY A STAMP ON IT, AND THEY
HAVE TO SIGN THE BALLOT. SO TO
AND THAT SIGNATURE HAS TO MATCH
WHAT'S ON FILE WITH THE STATE.
AND SO IF THEY SEND THEIR BALLOT
BACK TO THE STATE AND THE
SIGNATURE DOESN'T MATCH, BECAUSE
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN THEY WERE 16
AND THEY HADN'T WORKED OUT THEIR
SIGNATURE, THAT'S WHEN THEY
FIRST GOT THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE
AND THEY SIGNED THEIR NAME A
CERTAIN WAY. AND NOW, MANY YEARS
LATER, THEIR SIGNATURE IS
RADICALLY DIFFERENT. OR THEY
FORGOT TO SIGN IT. THEY JUST PUT
IT IN THE IN THE MAIL AND SENT
IT BACK. THEN AND THERE ARE
60,000. IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
60,000 OF THESE BALLOTS THAT ARE
REJECTED BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE SIGNATURE. SO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALLOWS A CURE PROCESS
SO THEY CAN FIX THE SIGNATURE SO
THEIR VOTE WILL COUNT, BECAUSE
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE COUNT EVERY
VOTE, RIGHT. WHEN PEOPLE WANT TO
VOTE, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE REGISTER THEIR VOTE. RIGHT.
SO THIS BILL IS AIMING TO MAKE
THAT MORE CLEAR. HOW EXACTLY THE
SIGNATURE PROBLEM WOULD GET
FIXED. EXACTLY. IS THAT TRUE?
AND IF THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE,
AND IF THERE'S ANY DEBATE AS TO
HOW IMPORTANT EVERY VOTE IS, THE
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTION IN MY
DISTRICT ENDED IN A TIE FOR THE
SECOND AND THIRD PLACE. JUST
THIS PAST PRIMARY. AND SO THAT
JUST SHOWS HOW IMPORTANT EVERY
VOTE IS. AND HOW EVERY, EVERY
VOTE COULD SWING THE ELECTION.
AND SO IF YOU IF YOU MADE THE
BEST FAITH EFFORT TO FOLLOW THE
RULES, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE YOUR
VOTE GETS COUNTED. THAT'S THAT'S
A GREAT POINT ABOUT YOUR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS. DO YOU
REMEMBER THE EXACT NUMBER THAT
WAS THE TIE? IT WAS IN THE
THOUSANDS. IT WAS TENS OF
THOUSANDS. YES, IT WAS TENS OF
THOUSANDS. THE EXACT SAME NUMBER
FOR TWO CANDIDATES. YEAH. IT'S
IT DOES REALLY MATTER EVERY
VOTE. SO WE NOW HAVE FOUR
MEMBERS HERE. SO WE COULD
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SO I WILL
ASK THE ASSISTANT TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BLAKE SPEAR
HERE. BLAKE SPEAR HERE. NGUYEN
ALLEN ALLEN HERE. MENGIBAR HERE.
MENGIBAR HERE. NEWMAN
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HERE.
UMBERG THANK YOU. I'LL MOVE THE
BACK. OKAY. AND DO ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS? YES OH, EXCELLENT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OFFER SUPPORT,
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, TIM
CARMODY, ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
OF STATE SHIRLEY WEBER, PROUD TO
CONTINUE TO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU FOR
COMING. LET'S SEE, DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS? I DO NOT SEE ANY.
AND WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR ALLEN. SO THE MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. AND WE WILL CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. THANK
YOU. SO, ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS BLAKE SPEAR.
YES. BLAKE. SPEAR. YES. ALLEN I
ALLEN I WHEN MENGIBAR I NAVARRE
I NEWMAN. PORTANTINO. HI
PORTANTINO I UMBERG. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THIS WILL REMAIN ON CALL.
HèA. TO EVERYONE ON THE. DO YOU
THINK WE SHOULD GO INTO RECESS
AS WE WAIT?
FOR THE SENATE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE WILL NOW GO INTO
RECESS.
RETURNED FROM RECESS FOR THE
SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE. AND WE HAVE ONE ITEM
AB3184 FROM BERMAN, AND WE WILL
LIFT THE CALL AND ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LIFTING
CALL FOR ITEM ONE AB 318 FOR
MOTION. IS THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION? CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO. CHAIR VOTED AYE WHEN
ALAN MENGIBAR NEWMAN NEWMAN I
UMBERG WAIT, DIDN'T SENATOR
ALLEN VOTE? HE DID I APOLOGIZE I
WENT OVER THIS OH OKAY. DO YOU
WANT TO JUST SAY IT AGAIN. YEAH.
OKAY. ONE NEWMAN HIGH NEWMAN I
UMBERG OKAY. IT'S VISOR AND THEN
WE'RE CLOSING THE RULE. IT'S
FIVE ZERO. WE ARE CLOSING THE
ROLL. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU EVERYBODY
OKAY? OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS IS ADJOURNED.